[Music]
Jason's playing Adam clay who's a
retired beekeeper he's always like a
super soldier that is there to protect
Society we meet him living in the barn
of a very sweet lady and she becomes a
victim of cyber crime yesterday she shot
herself I need to take care of the hive
it's an epic Vengeance story about one
man's desire to bring Justice you aware
this is a criminal outfit buddy I'm
count of three 1 2 3 there I did it for
you Adam Clay is on his side of the law
which is the right side will you stomp
his ass
out beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of
command here's a man who is actually
getting the job done
play we have wars for these things until
they fail then you have
me it's Jason Stam so we know the action
is going to be incredible he does his
own stunts and he's absolutely
Relentless once we set things in motion
we're off for a ride this is much bigger
than a little fishing
scam come on don't
move